okay I want to talk about a story
involving incoming president Donald and
my home country of Argentina there's
this broader background we've been
talking about with Donald and his
daughter Ivanka and and the entire
family really where there's this insane
conflict of interest that we've seen
where the lines between Trump as
president-elect and Trump as business
guy have been very blurred and this
includes having Ivanka in the room when
he met with Japanese Prime Minister
Shinzo Abbe in spite of not having a
security clearance in spite of being
legally forbidden from being part of
trumps administration because of
anti-nepotism laws that's a real concern
we learned that Donald Trump met with
Indian business associates but it really
seems sort of like a meeting that was
the president-elect that was doing the
meeting we also learned that Donald
Trump hosted about a hundred dignitaries
and diplomats from around the world at
his new DC hotel and they came out of
there saying hey listen of course we're
going to stay at the president's DC
hotel because we want to ingratiate
ourselves with him and especially if we
stay somewhere else we don't want to be
staying at the president's competition
we're talking about a president here
right not not a hotel magnate although
that is also one of Donald Trump's roles
we now have learned about some
allegations involving Donald and
Argentinean president Mauricio Macri who
has been a sort of center-right - right
wing a beautifully anti-corruption
candidate to replace Cristina Kirchner
who was the prior president and I don't
want to get into all the argentinian
politics that that could be discussed
here needless to say I started reading
reports in English about how Trump and
and makhani had a phone call and in that
phone call Trump allegedly asked the
Argentinean president for help moving
forward a stalled real estate project in
the city of my birth buenos itis in
Argentina and I saw that they were all
linking all these English articles
articles in English we're linking to one
particular article in the Argentinean
newspaper Lana
which means the nation and I looked at
that article and that article was just
linking to the monologue from an
Argentinian journalist named jorge
lanata who actually was here in Boston
not long ago and I saw him speak at
Harvard and this journalist just makes
the assertion that this is something
that was discussed during the phone call
between Trump and the Argentinean
president with no real sourcing beyond
that allegation so I want to be super
upfront with everybody this is a report
that we've seen the report is as yet
unsourced but it is from a journalist
who is actually more of a pro marketing
guy than anti on the whole so there's
not like an obvious political bias or or
vendetta which would see him make this
up and he's been right about a lot of
stuff in the past but still it's super
clear Pat that we need to say a lot of
articles in English when you look at the
Spanish article all it says is this one
guy alleged this yeah assuming it to be
true I mean it is troubling you think
that maybe it's just small talk but you
think that Donald Trump was had
something to say about the vision of his
country rather than just focusing on
something as trivial as one of his
building yeah a 35-foot office building
in winnow situs now of course when if we
were to hear this allegation and if it
had gone against everything that we've
already seen from Trump in the last 10
or 12 days since his election or closer
to 14 days at this point I guess then we
might say well it just sounds
unbelievable but it's quite the opposite
it sounds very believable
additionally we now have learned that
Trump's daughter Ivanka Trump was also
on the phone call with Argentinean
president Mauricio Macri but that is
being explained away by saying no Trump
and mockney have known each other for a
long time and Macri has known Ivanka
since she was a little kid so it was
just like a friendly phone call there's
always an explanation isn't there Pat
there's nothing to see here folks
yeah I'm sure if you were elected
president you would be having all your
family members talk with the Argentine
president everyone everybody would get
on the phone absolutely so you know
maybe again all that stuff that Donald
Trump talked about during the campaign
Hillary Clinton's using political power
for personal gain
maybe it was projection from Donald
Trump maybe it was jealousy maybe Donald
Trump was just jealous that he hasn't
yet been in a position to use political
power for personal financial gain and
now he's actually going to be in a
position to do that just what the
founding fathers had in mind right that
you could have a president who would use
their power to push ahead private
business deals to become personally
richer make America great again
that's what a lot of the Trump is voted
for and they are not going to benefit
from Trump using diplomatic phone calls
and meetings in DC - push business deals
forward that I think we all realize if
we think about it for a second but
unfortunately many of the trumpets are
refusing to see the light Gamefly is
sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low use price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash T DPS the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30 day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s